c'est une première pour les étudiants de
l'estaca l'école d'ingénieurs
spécialisée dans les nouvelles mobilités
proposé de découvrir et de tester les
véhicules innovants conçus par les
élèves
ils se sont déplacés de montigny le
bretonneux à l'autodrome de linas
montlhéry en essonne c'est pour mettre à
l'honneur la vie associative de notre
école ses étudiants ses partenaires ses
sponsors ses anciens élèves
donc les mettre à l'honneur voir les
véhicules en statique et dynamique qui
bien évidemment on est accueilli par
notre partenaire industriel qui est le
groupe it ac qui bénéficie d'équipements
prestigieux sur un circuit centenaires
parmi les véhicules innovants conçus par
les étudiants calypso son poids à vide
est de 37 kg ce véhicule thermique de
l'association pv 3e est arrivé troisième
aux derniers shell eco marathon de
londres
dans la catégorie moteur à combustion
interne calypso a parcouru plus de 1500
kilomètres avec un seul litre d'essence
on est un moteur qui ne consomme pas
c'est vrai c'est vraiment le nerf de la
guerre au niveau du shell eco marathon
c'est le moteur voilà on a également
l'aérodynamique avoir un véhicule qui
pénètrent bien dans l'air ici on voit
qu'il a été particulièrement soignée et
ensuite avoir finalement une dernier
point une bonne rigidité du châssis en
lui-même qui permettent donc voilà de
perdre on perd le minimum d'énergie en
fait dans le dans le véhicule tout
entier lors de son passage
ce véhicule a réussi à repousser les
limites de l'efficacité énergétique des
technologies utilisées par les étudiants
que l'on pourrait retrouver dans
l'automobile de demain